[Applaudissements]
les plaisirsois peuvent laisser éclater
leur joie les filles du CTC trap plaisir
Sky viennent de battre l'équipe des
Mureaux lors de la dernière journée du
championnat une victoire synonyme de
monter en régionale ce match les
joueuses l'ont maîtrisé de bout en bout
en étant largement devant des lapauses
le score 35 à 16 quand tu joues un match
pour le titre et que tu joues à domicile
avec ton public bien sûr ça pousse
davantage il faut aussi féliciter cette
équipe des Mureaux qui reste une bonne
équipe ce dimanche 16 avril rien ne
semblait pouvoir perturber les joueuses
locales au retour des vestiaires les
plaisirsoisses continuent à dérouler
l'emporte logiquement 69 à 35
donc c'est ça le mot du match ensemble
c'est au titre de notre saison à l'image
de notre saison on a fait ce qu'on
savait faire on s'est donné c'était un
match plaisir mais c'est jamais facile
on est resté dedans c'est pas facile
d'être concentré tout le match on a
réussi à le faire avec cette victoire
trap plaisir Sky thermique premier
devant l'équipe de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux avec un bilan de
16 victoires et de défaites l'équipe
commence déjà à se projeter sur la
saison prochaine il va falloir
reconstruire encore une fois parce qu'on
va monter de division donc forcément
c'est un niveau qui est supérieur ça va
demander beaucoup d'engagement beaucoup
de stratégies beaucoup de cohésion en
attendant de reconstruire les joueuses
veulent savourer une montée déjà
historique
[Applaudissements]